today on the mat wall show there is a
crisis in our culture of lonely
disaffected young men but anyone who
speaks up for them like Jordan Peterson
is villainized why we'll talk about that
today also a house hearing on abortion
descends once again into anti-science
nonsense Vice has a puff piece about sex
offenders that does not go according to
plan for them anyway Kamala Harris is
relatable at least to me for the first
time and in our daily cancellation we'll
deal with one of the great injustices
and outrages of all time it has to do
with somebody named Haley Bieber and the
color of her lipstick all of that and
more today on the Matt Walsh show
[Applause]
foreign
stores is that they have different price
tiers for professional mechanics and
do-it-yourselfers but think about
rockauto.com is that their prices are
the same for everybody and they're
always reliably low that's the best part
rockauto.com is a family-owned business
serving Auto Parts customers online for
20 years you can go to rockauto.com to
shop for auto and body parts from
hundreds of Manufacturers they've got
everything you could possibly need
engine control modules brake parts tail
lamps motor oil even new carpet and the
best thing again is that you get the
lowest prices possible on all of that
whether it's for your classic or your
daily driver you can get everything you
need with just a few easy clicks
delivered straight to your door you know
the rockauto.com catalog is remarkably
easy to navigate you don't need to know
a lot about cars to sort through it you
can quickly see all the parts available
for your vehicle and you can choose the
brands the specifications and the prices
that you prefer amazing selection
reliably low prices all the parts your
car will ever need go to rockauto.com
right now see all the parts available
for your car or truck remember to rock
rockauto.com and be sure to write Walsh
in there how did you hear about us box
so they know that I sent you
last week a film that had been grabbing
headlines for reasons that have nothing
to do with the film itself finally
premiered Olivia Wilde's don't worry
darling is from what I've read a sort of
feminist fever dream of a film a woke in
the extreme and yet of such low quality
that most movie critics have actually
panned it despite agreeing with and
applauding its politics now fortunately
for the critics Olivia Wilde is white
and I think straight and so they're
allowed to criticize her work you know
they're a lot they're actually allowed
to do that and so in this case they have
the movie had a relatively strong debut
at the box office
helped by all of the news coverage it
had gotten due to gossip and drama
behind the scenes the details of which
are too tedious and boring to bother
recapping here but sales began tumbling
a few days after the release as
audiences realized that the film is
garbage and word began to spread
um it's sort of unfortunate in a way you
know Hollywood finally puts out a movie
that isn't based on a comic book or some
other pre-existing brand
and it sucks so I have a feeling the
industry will learn all of the wrong
lessons from this outcome but months
before the film came out uh Wilde had
explained that the villain in the movie
is based on Jordan Peterson whose
excellent content by the way is now
available on daily wire plus uh Wilde
said that Peterson himself is quote a
hero to the in-cell community which she
defined as quote disenfranchised mostly
white men who believe they're entitled
to sex from women and they believe that
Society has now robbed them that the
idea of feminism is working against
nature and that we must put back into
the correct place
she then accused Peterson of quote
legitimizing certain aspects of their
movement because he's a former Professor
he's an author he wears a suit so they
feel like this is a real philosophy that
should be taken seriously
now almost everything that
you can hear in that quote there is
false and stupid it's like a seven layer
cake of wrongness just totally
ridiculous on multiple levels but how
does Jordan Peterson himself feel about
it well he was asked about it um by
Piers Morgan last night while he was uh
visiting uh Piers Morgan show and here's
what he said watch
and what I'll ask you just quickly the
film director Olivia Wilde is a new
movie out which she says is based on you
this insane man this pseudo-intellectual
hero to the in-cell community in cell
being these weirdo loner men uh who are
despicable in many ways is that you are
you the intellectual hero to these
people
sure why not you know
um
people have been after me for a long
time by because I've been speaking to
disaffected young men you know what a
terrible thing to do that is
I thought the marginalized were supposed
to have a voice
is making emotional talk about it well
God you know
it's very difficult to understand
how demoralized people are
and certainly many young men are in that
category and you get these casual
insults these these in cells what do
they mean it's like well these men
they're they don't know how to make
themselves attractive to women who are
very picky and good for them women like
be picky that's that's your gift man
demand high standards from your man fair
enough but all these men who are
alienated it's like
they're Lonesome and and and they don't
know what to do and everyone piles abuse
on them when she said that Olivia Wilde
it stung you didn't it that's all oh by
that time you know
that as far as as critic critiques go
that was kind of low level I mean once I
got painted as
Red Skull you know magical super Nazi
that was kind of the end of the insults
now Peterson has been trending today
because of that clip with the thousands
of leftists mocking him for becoming
emotional and slightly teary-eyed media
headlines from Outlets like variety
declare Jordan Peterson breaks down in
tears when asked about Olivia Wilde
calling him the hero to the incel
community now the headlines are of
course meant to stir up even more
mockery and they also are meant to give
the false impression that Peterson was
crying over the insult from Olivia Wilde
no obviously is not the case he makes
clear that he doesn't care what Olivia
Wilde says and why would he does anyone
he became emotional when speaking about
disaffected despairing young men
those were tears of empathy
not self-pity okay this was not a Taylor
Lorenz type crying fit it wasn't it was
it was in every way the opposite
but this is an interesting thing that
you might notice
the left constantly insists that men
should be less stoic should show more
emotion
and then when a man does exactly that
and shows emotion he's ruthlessly
ridiculed for it so they say that men
should be vulnerable but the moment that
any man actually takes them up on it his
vulnerability is wielded against him
used against him
and if men notice that this is how it
works and thus resolve to be even more
closed off and reserved they'll be
accused of toxic masculinity it's it's a
game that men cannot win because no
matter what they say or do no matter how
they react to any situation they lose
and that is really the point isn't it
Jordan Peterson has noticed the ways
that our culture Stacks the deck against
young men isolates them disenfranchises
them alienates them
he speaks with empathy to and about this
group of people and that's the primary
reason why he is hated so much by the
left people like Olivia Wilde have made
it clear that young men should be
lectured and nagged and are treated with
disdain
we should make no attempt to understand
them least of all guide them and
Champion them well we can't do that
and that's why anyone who does so any
figure who comes along and tries to give
alienated young men a voice
and thus earns a large following of
exactly those kinds of men is going to
get kicked off social media D platform
villainized Etc we've seen this play out
countless times not just with Jordan
Peterson
man can you think of an example of a
public figure who has garnered an
audience who's known to have garnered an
audience largely of men and yet has not
been labeled controversial because of it
the message is made loud and clear
you may ignore these people
or you may demonize them
but you must not treat them with respect
or advocate for them or try to
understand them
because if you do that you're a danger
you're a threat
you're a hero to the in-cell community
of course we have to keep in mind that
whenever anyone on the left uses the
term incel they simply mean
all men who are not a vowed woke
leftists that's what an incel is it is
at this point nothing but an anti-male
slur used against literally any man
who's judged to be a political enemy
you don't need to gather on 4chan and
you certainly don't need to be an
involuntary celibate to earn the title I
mean they use that term against me and I
have a wife and six kids if you could be
an in cell while driving your family in
your 12 passenger van to church then the
term obviously has a much broader
meaning it's just another way another
label meant to stigmatize and alienate
and it works
because
no matter what you think
no matter what image you have of the
world
no matter what your politics or your
ideology demands you believe
no matter how deeply you believe in the
fiction of male privilege the fact is
that a huge number of men in our culture
especially young men are deeply lonely
lost
frustrated
isolated
I mean I hear from these men every day
Jordan Peterson hears from them at an
exponentially greater volume that's why
he gets emotional when he talks about
the issue because encountering the
depths of other people's despair every
day takes a toll
I mean it's an enormous burden
an emotional burden that sociopaths on
the left can't understand I mean they
they literally can't understand empathy
when they see it they just laugh at it
because they don't know what else to do
with it
but it leaves us again with this Stark
fact that these men exist
and denying that they exist only
contributes to the problem
but it's it's easy to see why the left
doesn't want to acknowledge you know the
societal crisis of marginalized
disenfranchised young men because for
one thing the left has this complicated
uh ever-changing victim pyramid to
maintain and a victim pyramid requires a
villain you know with all those victims
around we need someone to do the
victimizing
men especially white men have been
assigned to that role but much as comic
book films don't usually spend too much
time humanizing their super their super
villains for fear that they might you
know become too sympathetic and then
you're not going to root for the good
guys anymore so too does the left avoid
humanizing their own chosen villains and
for the same reason
that's why they treat it like a big
secret like no no you're not these
people aren't human beings okay no no no
we have we we can describe these people
in one sentence and you're not allowed
to go beyond that sentence
there's a deeper reason also why they
would prefer to ignore this group
and that's because young men and young
women in this culture are suffering from
Despair and hopelessness and purpose
purposelessness
because this is what the sexual
Revolution and our cultures continued
Lurch leftward has brought
you know if you acknowledge the men if
you take their pain seriously
then you've opened a conversation that
the left doesn't want to have
because it's a conversation about how
all of their promises have been empty
their Revolution failed
I mean they created despair where they
promised happiness
and uh emptiness where they promised
fulfillment
that's why these men must continue to be
ignored
and anyone who speaks for them
silenced
now let's get to our five headlines
foreign
[Music]
so there was a house oversight Committee
hearing on abortion yesterday uh yet
another one so they have committee
hearings on abortion it seems like uh
three or four times a week and they had
another one here a few moments worth
revisiting I think we'll start with Dr
bhavik Kumar uh Kumar identifies as a
trans and abortion care provider and was
brought on as an expert witness
and there are a couple of moments here
we'll start with this where uh we're
told that among other things
um hurricanes require abortions there's
a connection between hurricanes and
abortions
how could that possibly be the case well
let's listen to uh the connection as
it's made here
this Nationwide abortion ban 15-week
Nationwide abortion Bank Dr Kumar a 2021
study predicted a 21 increase in
pregnancy related deaths if a abortion
ban were imposed with black women facing
a predicted increase of 33 percent can
you explain to us why there would be an
increase in pregnancy related deaths as
well as more black women a 33 percent
increase in black women dying uh as well
sure thank you for that question
um what I would point to First is a
recent CDC report that low temperature
maternal mortality in our country and
actually found that four out of five of
those deaths are preventable some of the
top conditions that they talked about
were mental health conditions such as
suicidality or depression excessive
bleeding referred to as Hemorrhage
cardiac conditions which are highest
among black women and also hypertension
related conditions all of these things
are preventable when we look at today's
landscape of abortion access and we talk
about a 15 we ban we can look at Florida
for example what's happening today with
a natural disaster hurricane again as
that state has a 15-week ban and we
think about what's happening to families
what's happening to their homes folks
that may be 13 weeks pregnant or even 10
weeks pregnant as they deal with the
things that they're having to deal with
in their life they're being pushed
further and further into pregnancy when
we look at the landscape around
accessing abortion and The Limited
number of clinics that are still
available in Haven States and how long
people are waiting sometimes several
weeks that's also pushing them further
into pregnancy so these impacts are
always felt disproportionately by people
of color especially low-income folks and
also black folks and that's what we'll
continue to see but it will only worsen
from here
my God these people are such demonic
satanic freaks I mean they really are
the problem so so what we're worried
about with the hurricane is that it's
pushing people into pregnancy so it's a
hurricane
uh slamming Florida and uh destroying
wide swaths of the state and cities and
people are getting swept away and houses
are destroyed but the thing that Dr
Bobby Kumar is worried about is that
it's going to push people into pregnancy
well this this hurricane might uh might
lead to fewer babies dying
just think about what a twisted
sociopathic bloodthirsty Goblin you have
to be to see a hurricane the first thing
that comes to mind is oh my God
more babies might be born because of
this
and but somehow that's not even the most
uh the the the you know the the headline
from the clip you just heard there
because right before that we're told and
this is an important Point actually
because they talk about the maternal
mortality rate and
of course everybody agrees that maternal
mortality uh people you know women dying
in childbirth is a a terrible thing we
have to do everything we can to prevent
it
but on the left they're very invested in
making childbirth seem as dangerous as
possible
I mean the great thing about living in
the first world you know in in a western
in western civilization
is that maternal mortality is uh you
know it's
childbirth is very very safe so it's a
rare exception when somebody dies from
childbirth
um in this country in modern times it
wasn't always that way it isn't that way
necessarily in other in in other parts
of the world in third world countries
where they don't have access to the same
medical care but in this country it is I
mean it does happen but it's rare thank
God
right
but on the left they're very invested in
making and making child you know
childbirth seem even more dangerous they
want it to be dangerous
because then they can use it
as a rationale for having more abortions
but there are a couple problems here
first of all you heard him say
that when it comes to more maternal
mortality you know the number one cause
is suicidality and depression
and so they're counting suicide as a
death caused by childbirth
they're they're including that in
maternal mortality the maternal
mortality rate according to what we just
heard there suicide
now of course when they if they don't
specify that and you hear about maternal
mortality nobody thinks suicide you
don't think of that as a as a directly
caused by childbirth I mean you're
thinking of someone of a woman
tragically bleeding out during
childbirth or something like that
that's what they want you to think about
but as we just heard they're they're
sort of padding the stats by adding
suicide to it now
it's true that you know postpartum
depression is a real problem
and tragically there are women who
commit suicide suffering from postpartum
depression
the question though
is can you solve that problem through
abortion
so you kill the baby does that solve the
depression problem
let me ask you something
how
so we know about uh suicide which they
link to postpartum depression
what about suicide linked to
post-abortion depression
we have any stats on that
well no there are basically no stats on
this because it never happens it never
happens because women never regret their
abortions
that's total nonsense we know but
there's there's no one who feels uh you
know the the people who are in charge of
tabulating these things there's there's
no real incentive for them to keep track
of that
but of course we know the reality is
that um while postpartum depression is a
very real problem
it is thank God most of the time
temporary women get through it
the guilt and regret and despair that
comes from abortion on the other hand
can be lifelong
never goes away
but if a woman
five months after an abortion or 15
years after an abortion commits suicide
because she can't deal with the guilt
anymore we're never going to be told
about that it just won't tell us that
that link will never be made in any
official sort of context
foreign
then the conversation moved on and got
more bizarre as we get to this exchange
between the doctor and a republican
lawmaker on the issue of whether
men can get pregnant
and
you feel like you kind of know what the
answer is going to be but there's
there's one part of this answer that's
pretty interesting so I want you to
listen to this
Dr Kumar can biological men become
pregnant and give birth
um so men can have pregnancies
especially trans men so can biological
men become pregnant and give birth so
are you saying that a biological female
who identifies as a man in therefore
becomes pregnant is quote a man is that
what you're saying these questions about
who can become pregnant are really
missing the point I'm here to talk no no
no no no no no this is me asking a
question and you answering I'm asking
the question sir not you right and I'm
answering the question somebody with a
uterus may have a capability of becoming
pregnant whether they're a woman or a
man that doesn't mean okay we're done
not every person
let me tell you if a person has this
medicine and is born as a is born female
they are a woman that is not a man and
the vast majority of the world considers
that to be a woman because there are
biological differences between men and
women
I mean clearly any high school biology
class teaches that men and women have
different chromosomes females are XX
chromosome and male are X Y chromosome I
can't believe it's necessary to say this
but men cannot get pregnant and cannot
get birth give birth regardless of how
they identify themselves
uh so we we see these exchanges now
every time pretty much anytime there's a
any Hearing in the in the house that we
get we get this question from Republican
lawmaker can men give birth what is a
woman and I think it's great it's
fantastic this is exactly what you
should be doing
um and especially if they're there to
talk about anything related to pregnancy
if they're there to talk about anything
science related
um then yes you should get them on the
record
uh endorsing the idea that men can give
birth so that's that is a this is this
is progress for the Republican party I'm
glad they're doing it uh but you notice
the response there the response was
yes men can give get pregnant
especially trans men especially not only
but especially now a trans man quote
unquote is a woman who identifies as a
man and yes we all know that those
individuals I mean if they haven't uh
mutilated or their body or or sterilize
themselves yet
um they can get pregnant
so we know that yes it's a woman who who
calls herself something else or mentally
identifies another way can still get
pregnant she still has all the functions
of a woman that's our Point that's what
we're saying
that that actually helps us
that yes no matter how you identify
unless you unless you go to a surgeon
and tell them to start removing parts of
your body
doesn't matter if no matter how you
identify your your
biological essence
the biological reality remains
but what about but but it's chilly
so especially means that well in in
particular
uh women who identify as men can get
pregnant
but since you're using the word
especially that would seem to indicate
that even non-trans men can get pregnant
so the claim that we just heard from
that doctor
is that not only women who identify as
men can get pregnant but actual
biological men
can get pregnant
this is what we hear from doctors now
something that we unfortunately again
always have to keep in mind
when you're going to the doctor you're
Consulting any any health care
professional
not saying that you never should I'm not
saying that you should uh
you know swear off modern medicine
entirely that wouldn't be a good idea
for your own health and safety but
you do have to keep in mind that much of
the medical profession is totally
compromised and has been claimed by this
absolute abject insanity
um and has lost its grip on physical
reality so you gotta remember that and
just be cautious and look out for that
a little bit later on AOC chimed in and
had a rebuke for the transphobia that we
just heard there but but something also
to say before that let's listen
briefly I'd like to address some of the
prior claims that uh and prior several
prior immediate claims one being that
abortion is not an economic issue and
that we should be focused on economic
issues and I also you know I think it's
important to state that
um that abortion is an economic issue
forcing poor and working-class people uh
to give birth
um against their will against their
consent
um against their ability to provide for
themselves or a child is a profound
economic issue and it's certainly a way
to keep
um a Workforce uh
basically conscripted uh to large-scale
employers and two employers to be to
work more against their will to take
second and third jobs against their
desire and their own autonomy and so the
idea that
um that abortion and access to abortion
is somehow not a profound and Central
economic and class issue and class
struggle is certainly something that I
think a person who's never had to
contend uh with the ability to carry a
child
um you know it belies that perspective
um and it's disappointing to see
um but secondly I think another thing
that I'd like to address is that the
same folks who tell who tell us and told
us that clovid kovid's just a flu that
climate change isn't real that January 6
was nothing but a tourist visit are the
same are now trying to tell us that
transgender people are not real and I
would say that their claim is probably
just as legitimate as all their others
which is to say not very much at all
cheers
so stupid all the time
and it's not it's not a put on it's not
an act I mean some of these people on
the left there are people on the left
are quite intelligent and they're the
ones you have to work watch out for the
most uh they're very smart and and um
and scheming and devious and they say
things that they know aren't true
but
I don't think that's true for AOC I
think she actually is
enormously dumb
you know uh that's that's what I think
the issue is for her so when she says
the trans people exist you're denying
the existence of trans people I I I'm
willing to believe that she actually
believes that that's the issue here
but of course it isn't
no one is denying that quote trans
people obviously we know that otherwise
we wouldn't be having this conversation
how can you claim in one in one breath
that we're transphobic and the other
breath we're denying the existence of
trans people if they don't exist then
there's no so if are we afraid of them
or do we deny they exist because if
before denying that they exist then
there'd be nothing to be afraid of
you got to choose one or the other
now both are not correct but at least
choose one falsehood or the other not
two falsehoods that contradict each
other
people who
identify as trans exist people who make
uh the claim that they are a sex other
than what they were born at Birth exist
those people exist however the claims
they are making about reality are false
that's what we're saying we're denying
their claims
not their physical existence you [ __ ]
what she says before that is even worse
though because she's exactly wrong she's
she is she's she's chosen a position
that is the diametric she's like on the
South Pole and what is and the truth is
the North Pole she's in the she's the
all she couldn't get farther away from
the truth
she says
that it's kind of a conspiracy among
corporations and the wealthy
um to push abortion Bans
you know because it helps their own
bottom line what
what major corporations are supporting
abortion bans
almost every single one of them have
come out and denounced abortion bans and
not only that but a lot of these
corporations are paying
to send their employees to other states
to get abortions
that's what the corporations are doing
you ignoramus
that's what almost all of them are doing
and why would they do that
because it's better for the corporation
that's better for your employer if you
kill your child because then you have
more time to spend at work
it doesn't help how does it help your
job if you have a baby
especially as a woman it means that you
got you have the baby you take maternity
leave
and now you have something else in your
life that is claiming your time and
attention you have something that is
pulling you away from the job especially
as a woman
well the employers they don't want that
the corporations they don't want that so
uh so they're they're going to ship you
off and they'll say sure we'll pay for
your abortion yeah go ahead we'll do
that
means you have more time for us it means
that we as the corporation we Remain the
focus of your life we don't want the
baby to be the focus of your life we
don't want your family to be the focus
of your life we want us we want what
happens here in this building in your in
your dumb little cubicle we want that to
be the thing that's most important to
you
and that's why they pay for the
abortions
so she she literally could not be more
wrong about that
all right
let's move on before I get heated too
late probably uh so this shouldn't be
funny but it is and you've probably seen
this clip already but I have to play it
anyway uh Vice put together a puff piece
about how Society is
um uh too mean to sex offenders and we
need to treat sex offenders better we
have to reintegrate them into society uh
poor victims and all that and the report
ended this way
I'm definitely hopeful I like the
position I'm in I ain't gonna let
stop stop me not even this or
or DNA or
a person's opinion like we all out here
in this world
and we all got to make it happen and it
ain't non-stopping me so like I'm very
hopeful confident
[Music]
this interview she sent a picture of his
penis to our producer
he later said through his lawyer that he
sent it by mistake
uh
a mistake very plausible excuse
it's a shame too that it turns out he's
still a sexual deviant because uh I
thought I thought his his insights were
quite profound you know he said uh he's
not gonna let anything any any stuff
stop him
you know we all got to make it happen in
life
that that's that's real insight that's
Camilla Harris level insight
you know
so uh turns out you know he's he's one
of the people being profiled let's
reintegrate him into society and he he
sexually harasses one of The Producers
on the story that is meant to paint him
in a positive light
um there was a follow-up interview with
a producer of this uh of this um
segment you know asking you know what
what happened behind the scenes why did
this happen and why did you decide to
include it in the report and let's
listen
I wanted to ask you about what it was
like what it was like to find out that a
chief had sent that picture to one of
your producers I mean I was shocked I I
was angry
if this was something that happened from
a stranger you would just block the
person and never talk to them again but
we're journalists and we were working
with a chief on this so we reached out
to him we got comment
um you know we reached out to his
lawyers uh he says he sent it by mistake
um which I think is up for the viewers
to decide whether they believe that or
not was it hard to decide whether to use
that information or not in the piece
yeah we went back and forth a lot about
it because on the one hand you could
argue that it's not relevant to the
story of the Injustice that a chief
faced at the hands of the state all of
the years of dead time that he served um
you know that's really what our story
was about
um and his lawyers would argue that uh
you know the fact that of the pick isn't
relevant but we wanted to basically give
the full story to our viewers in a piece
that's also about what it means to
reintegrate successfully and
unsuccessfully as someone who's on the
sex offense registry this seemed like
you know an important fact to note about
a chief who is a complex person and this
is part of his complexity
it's part of his complexities he sends
pictures of his penis to uh that's okay
I guess you've you've just given that
rationale to any
it's any future scumbag men and they
have
not why did you give that Teddy to men
during me too maybe maybe Harvey
Weinstein could have said that you know
this is all this is all part of my
complexity
when he sent a picture of his penis he
was actually it was actually he was
showing his complexity there's a
euphemism for you
now she says that well it's not really
relevant
it's not it's not relevant to how the
state treated uh poor a chief
which just shows that these people they
cannot learn they they just can't learn
you're doing a puff piece on sex
offenders claiming they should be
reintegrated Society you get sexually
harassed by one of them and it still
isn't enough for you to that's not a
wake-up call
so she says it's not relevant to how the
state treated him of course it is it's
very relevant
because the whole point
is that he's clearly still a danger to
society he's out there that's sexual
harassment
so he's out there sexually harassing
women and just think about this for a
minute if he's willing to do that okay
if he's going to do that
to the producer of a you know of a of a
new of a segment
in which he is painted as a protagonist
and he would do that in that context
then what else is he doing
I mean we can't know this is one of the
problems one of the problems one of the
many problems
of releasing sex offenders back into
society is that uh much of what they do
you know we We aren't ever going to know
the vast majority of sex offended sex
offenses go unreported
and even if they're reported many of
them are almost impossible to prove
unless you're stupid enough to do it
you know with your with your phone
through pictures that you're sending to
people in which case it's very easy
um
that's the thing about a lot of these uh
sex offenses committed by these creeps
is that there's kind of a scale and and
many of them are really easy to prove
because they're doing it they they leave
a digital paper paper trail but then
there's a whole other category they're
almost impossible to prove
but yes it's it's all relevant because
it shows that yes this is someone
who you have selected
because it helps to prove your who you
thought helped to prove your point
and even he turns out to be still a
danger to society
that's just that's the nature of this
kind of crime
the people who behave this way who treat
others this way
um
it is very difficult to rehabilitate
them
you can't say it's impossible
and like we can't say that it's that
it's categorically impossible for
someone to change I mean
anyone in theory can change
but out of the outside of the realm of
theory and in reality the vast majority
of these people will never change that's
just that's and we could talk about why
that is and it gets into psychological
facts and spiritual facts but uh the
fact still is that the vast majority
never change
so what happens when you take them and
you put them in prison
and you have them kind of suing in that
environment with other sociopaths and
dangerous people and scumbags and you
have them stewing in that environment
for several years and then you release
them back into society
are they likely to be less dangerous
magically during that time
no even more so
I mean you could argue that if you're
going to take a dangerous sex offender
put them in jail for three years and
then release them you might as well not
put them in jail at all
because all you're doing is now delaying
the inevitable and you're and you're
putting them in an environment where
they're only going to get worse
and then you're inflicting them on
society
so it seems to me the most logical and
practical thing is that if you're going
to put these people in prison which
obviously we should uh you keep them
there
for a very long time if not forever
all right we're gonna kind of skip ahead
here I don't think this is five it might
be four headlines today because I want I
did want to play this for you too uh
this is Camilla Harris
and I'm playing this for you because
this is the one I've never found her to
be relatable
at all
this is this is her one relatable moment
because here she is visiting the
demilitarized zone between North and
South Korea
and she's talking to people who've got a
lot on their mind okay they're dealing
with it's a it's a there are plenty of
things they have to worry about being in
the DMZ and uh she thought though it was
a good time to have this conversation
but it's exciting have you seen the
photographs
it's humbling so we invested in this
telescope
and the images just came there and they
show us
three billion years back to the
beginning
it's the most humbling thing you've ever
seen you gotta have somebody here for it
it's absolutely healthy galaxies we
didn't know existed
the one we think we've seen everything
looks like okay I'm ready
this is why you shouldn't smoke weed
before visiting the demilitarized zone
and you got to feel for those Military
Officers because they're they're
standing there
thinking to themselves why are you
telling me this what what are you
babbling about and yet
she's talking about outer space and all
the cool stuff happening in outer space
in a very uninformed way uh going on
about how awesome it is to people who do
not care and in a context where it could
not be more irrelevant
and for that reason I have never found
her more relatable than in that moment
because that is what I do all the time
that's why I do on the show about three
or four times a week so we at least have
that in common we have nothing else
but at least we have that
let's get to the comment section
[Music]
[Music]
Marissa says whoa who would have thought
that if during the summer of love we
simply got lizzo to twerk on the statues
leftists would have thought history is
cool and stop tearing them down yeah I
mean that brings up another important
point about this uh this lizzo
James Madison flew
situation
which is that they're all pretending to
find the flute cool so it's a nice cool
piece of uh piece of History
because of its ties to James Madison
but we know they don't really see it
that way since when have they thought
that anything related to the founding
fathers was cool
this is the only time you know these
people in media say oh that's awesome
it's something that James Madison
since when have you cared about that
no usually anything we could tie back to
the founding fathers is problematic and
bad and Evil
so that's just how you know the claim
that this was done
um out of respect for the founding
fathers in American history you know
right off the bat that that's not true
because these people have no respect for
American history at least of all the
founding fathers
all right PG says I didn't think pigs
could fly but now I know they can play
the flute
Sean says sorry Matt lizzo is proof you
can indeed grow up to be a walrus
I'm disappointed in those comments we
don't make
we don't body shame we don't
deeply
deeply disappointed in both of you
Ethan says to destroy a people you must
first sever their Roots quoting
Alexander soljin Easton uh which yes
this is now you you could say the flute
thing is a rather Petty example of it
the more dramatic examples are tearing
down the statues taking names off of
buildings and all the rest of it
um
but as we talked about yesterday the
pettiness is the point that's part
that's part of the point here is that to
find these really
small superficial ways
of kind of driving the knife in deeper
and that's what this was
um
Jimmy says lizzo playing a Priceless
piece of history that the other 332
million people that live in this country
will likely never even see let alone
hold and play proves once again just how
underrepresented and oppressed she
really is stunning and brave uh yeah
that is another there are other comments
making that observation as well that
along with everything else this once
again goes to show
that although we're told someone like
lizzo being that she's a you know racial
minority she's a woman she's overweight
she checks a lot of victim boxes and yet
she is being honored in a way that
according to her nobody else ever has
been in the history in American history
so that's what it means to be oppressed
apparently
um and District 97 says funny how Matt
and other conservatives didn't even know
this flute existed until seven seconds
ago but yet are indignant about this
that is the laziest response to this I
have to tell you District 97
um uh with all due respect you know that
that's the the laziest response possible
and the dumbest you don't even know the
flute existed
you're right I didn't know the fluid
existed I uh guilty is charged I did not
know that James Madison had a crystal
flute dating back to 1813. I I didn't
know that
you're you're right
you know what there are many things in
the Smithsonian in fact almost every
artifact in the Smithsonian right now
because it's been a long time since I've
been there I have no direct knowledge of
and there are many things that the um uh
you know there there are many things
archived that I have no knowledge no
direct knowledge of
there are many Priceless artifacts and
works of art that I right now could not
list off for you
and yet I would still be opposed to
those things being defaced
so if someone if I hear about someone
um defacing uh you know a Michelangelo
painting
that I never heard of I'm not going to
say oh I never heard of that one who
cares yeah go ahead I only care about
the ones that I had heard of before this
moment
what
yeah I in I in principle IM opposed to
defiling defacing desecrating
disrespecting uh Priceless historical
artifacts that's across the board I'm
opposed to all of it whether I've heard
of them or not
that's my position
quite radical I know
in the dense emotional fog and mass
hysteria that was the infamous historic
wall walrus Gate scandal I almost forgot
to release a patch in the most highly
coveted patch program in the history of
patch programs yes I'm Matt Walsh still
have a patch program that I did not
forget about I could never forget about
it and that's why this month's patch is
the sweet baby walrus patch it is a
Beacon of Hope a light at the end of the
proverbial tunnel where the shadowy
figure at the end is a giant stuffed
walrus of arguably inconvenient size and
questionable utility as always these are
limited edition and will sell out fast
so you don't want to wait uh while
you're in my shop you can also pick up
our own official Johnny The Walrus
plushie so you can go to dailywire.com
shop to get the latest installment in
the Matt Walsh patch program and your
very own walrus today also I'm going to
speak to a segment of my audience I've
never directly addressed before
frat guys
where the hell is this going I have no
idea
you know I may not be one of you but in
some ways We're Not So Different you and
I we're both unfairly portrayed by the
media and we're both among the men most
hated by oh the woke razor companies and
leftist ideology which is unfortunate
when you consider the fraternities raise
millions of dollars every year for
charity one Virginia Tech fraternity
alone raised 255 thousand dollars for
Saint Jude's Children's Hospital last
year so with that influence and Moxie in
mind I thought I'd share an idea that I
obviously had I had this idea that I'm
reading for the first time from a
teleprompter you know Jeremy's Razor's
contest to win the car the one where you
can win Jeremy's McLaren well
we get that you don't want to shuttle
everybody around in a two-seater sports
car that's why if you win you can take
the 250 000 cash prize instead so I'm
sure your imagination will suffice to
paint a picture of all the fun and
Goodwill that a quarter million dollars
will enable for you and your friends
listen most of the top players in the
contest still haven't hit the 10
referral marks so there's plenty of
opportunity for you to jump into the
race and take it all Take the Money and
Run uh just go to Jeremy's razors.com
play to get your referral link and come
November 1st 2022 we'll see which of you
is the most woke free Fraternity in
America
peace out dudes is that even current
lingo for frat guys anyway
terms and conditions apply
now let's get to our daily cancellation
[Music]
so Haley Bieber is I'm going to assume
Justin Bieber's wife or um
I guess she could be a sister based on
the last name I didn't feel like
checking Wikipedia so you know these
things will remain a mystery all I know
is that Haley Bieber came under intense
scrutiny this week sparked backlash
provoked outrage as the media puts it
for wearing a certain color lipstick now
you may not have realized that there are
significant implications to the color of
one's lips but that is apparently the
case I don't make the rules
if I did we would live in a better
Society I think better for some of us
anyway not better for the sorts of
people who have turned lipstick into a
political issue under my Theocratic
fascist regime all such people would be
exiled to a Barren volcanic island
somewhere in the remote Pacific where
they would be free to live out their
lives for as long as their survival
skills will sustain them which I guess
would be about 45 minutes or so and
certainly on the first boat to that
Island under my regime
would be the entire cast of ABC's Good
Morning America which earlier this week
did an entire report in fact their cover
story on the Haley Bieber lipstick
controversy here it is
now we're going to go to our GMA cover
story Haley Bieber faces the cover story
it's very important you have to realize
after sharing a makeup look on Tick Tock
with some users causing the look
cultural appropriation Stephanie Ramos
has the details good morning those
racist lips good morning Haley Bieber
doesn't claim to have invented this
particular lip combo in her video the
brown lip liner and the clear lip gloss
but that post about that combo led to an
influx of tick tock users recreating the
look on the platform and crediting
Bieber She's embarrassed as a reporter
to be doing this others calling it
cultural appropriation it's a moment
where she looks in the mirror this
morning supermodel Haley Bieber facing
backlash after sharing her new lip
routine on Tick Tock with the caption
ready for all the fall things including
brownie glazed lips
[Music]
the now viral post causing a wave of
criticism social media users calling out
the supermarkets
are appropriating the makeup routine
using dark lip liner and clear lip gloss
a popular style from the late 80s and
90s I know that that lip combo is not
Haley Bieber lips it is a Latina and
black woman lymph you got her you're
right is when something is sort of
presented as if it's something new when
it's a practice that has been around for
decades and decades African-American and
Latino women get denigrated for the ways
that they present their body the way
their hair people use words like ghetto
or ratchet or that have these identities
to denigrate women it was ghetto it was
trashy it was not cute many pointing out
that the lip style was accepted when a
white woman did it but not when a woman
of color did it okay
that's right this this report went on by
the way for several more minutes
about the lipstick
now
they're making it sound like Haley
Bieber literally stole a black woman's
actual lips like ripped them off and
super glued them onto herself like some
kind of weird female Tick-Tock version
of Leatherface and if that's what she
had done I would be the first to condemn
her it is inappropriate I will say right
now to steal another person's facial
features without their consent I have
been very consistent in denouncing such
crimes as you know if you've listened to
the show but that is not exactly what
happened here instead Haley Bieber
simply put on some lipstick which
presumably she didn't pickpocket out of
a black woman's purse but rather
purchased from the store so the lipstick
is rightfully hers by any legal or moral
standard now
we don't need to spend a lot of time I
think explaining why the cultural
appropriation charge is always stupid
especially in this specific case
um because there are two ways of looking
at this issue
if by cultural appropriation you mean
that someone an outsider an interloper
is stealing a product or style or
concept or aesthetic or type of music or
whatever from an entire culture
if that's what you mean then cultural
appropriation understood that way is a
myth because by definition stealing
means two things first that a thing is
being taken without permission and
second that the victim of this theft is
now deprived of the thing that was
stolen so this is how it works when you
steal a car or a piece of jewelry or
five dollars out of somebody's wallet
but neither of those conditions can be
met in any case of cultural
appropriation because the thing that's
allegedly being appropriated is not
owned by any individual and so there's
no one to seek permission from
you can't steal what's not owned
also nobody is deprived of the thing
that has supposedly been appropriated
black women are not prevented from
wearing brown lipstick just because
Haley Bieber wore it
that is this is not therefore a case of
theft but if by cultural appropriation
you mean simply that someone is adopting
a concept style idea Etc that originated
or was developed by another culture then
cultural appropriation does indeed exist
and it's also a very good thing
we used to call this cultural exchange
and it was considered a positive and
enriching thing until The Tick-Tock
Pitchfork mob took over the country
along with being positive and enriching
it's also inevitable cultures are not
static they're not these immutable
blocks of concrete separated from each
other by impenetrable force fields
especially not in today's world but they
never were even in ancient times
cultures are living breathing organisms
basically they to use a term popular in
every context except where it actually
applies cultures are fluid they change
over time for better or worse
in the case of modern Western culture
most of the recent changes have fallen
into the latter category they've been
for the worst but whether good or bad
cultures will change
and they will borrow and they will learn
from each other
now of course I don't really need to
explain any of this do I
because the people who rail against
cultural appropriation already
understand all of it that's why they
would never in a million years suggest
that non-white people ought to refrain
from using or wearing or partaking in
things that originated with white people
you'll never hear them say that a racial
minority is culturally appropriating by
wearing denim jeans or using electricity
this only ever goes in One Direction
because it's actually got nothing to do
with culture and everything to do with
finding it another way and another
reason to criticize denigrate and
control white people
and inventing rules that only one race
of people have to follow and no other
race of people has to follow is racist
and that's what most of this is about
but the complaints about cultural
appropriation also speak to something
else
that is that many people in our society
are bored unserious and frivolous in the
extreme they have no purpose in life
they have nothing to strive for or
struggle against
they are oppressed by their own comfort
and security
they go out looking for dragons to slay
in order to give their lives meaning but
they don't have the energy or courage or
spiritual depth to find and confront the
true evils in this world of which there
are many so instead they look for the
easiest targets
problems they can solve by making a tick
tock video or participating in a hashtag
campaign
they are deeply miserable and teetering
always on the edge of full-blown despair
but they're too shallow to understand
their own misery and so they blame it on
the most superficial and frivolous
things imaginable
they are flailing around totally lost
living lives utterly devoid of meaning
or consequence and that's really why
they complain about Haley Bieber's
lipstick
or about whatever they're whining about
today having already moved on from that
controversy and on to another one and
then another forever and ever until they
die old and alone having wasted their
lives caring about everything except the
things actually worth caring about
and that's why they are today
canceled now I'll do it for this portion
of the show as we move over to the
members block hope to see you there if
not talk to you on Monday
happy flannel Friday Godspeed
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]